I have some new tour dates to announce
we've added a fourth and fifth show in
Toronto on August 23rd and August 24th
at the Elgin Theater it looks like a
beautiful place to be at and I'm really
looking forward to that tickets for
those shows are available now
theovan.com
t-o-u-r as well we will be adding uh
future shows for Houston for Phoenix
places that are selling out
um I don't want you guys buying crazy
overpriced tickets on resale sites so
make sure to check through theovan.com
t-o-u-r and uh we'll come back to those
cities so just be patient wherever uh
the shows are if you if you happen to be
missing out and thank you so much for
your support we also have a few tickets
left for Medford Massachusetts
uh we will come back to Boston as well
so don't
don't break your bank
um New York City Las Vegas Uncasville
Connecticut and uh or Uncasville and
Atlantic City
uh get all your tickets at theovan.com
t-o-u-r that's all Return of the Rat
tour we now have be good to yourself
crewnecks available in light blue maroon
and cement that embankment gang color
you know it check these out along with
the new windbreaker at
theovonstore.com and thank you for your
support
today's guest is a host a creature and
an interviewer he's known for his Sunday
conversations on Barstool Sports
um and he is a friend
that I just got back from a hunting trip
with doing uh hunting turkey
so we did it and we'll discuss it uh
today's guest is my friend Caleb Presley
[Music]
I'll sit and tell you my stories
and I
think
[Applause]
oh man
dude I feel uh
you're insane dude
that's too long
you think you're rattling boy
do your body your head's rattling
you're sitting there for too long I
think you do
it's just 10 I mean we did we did
probably about 13 minutes in there yeah
we were in a we had there's dual
I mean I feel damn fancy saying this
there's two ice baths now damn dude
like what's even the purpose have you
ever even had someone come over and do
it with you before never this is the
first time that was the closest thing
I've ever been probably to
kind of queering around with somebody
dude honestly
I don't know if that's or just not I
don't want to say that that was probably
the most
the bravest thing I've done with another
man
it's like 32 degrees out too
so it's not even warm when you get out
dude I just feel like it's got to
recover for a minute
yeah I feel like a bunch of snow just
tried to [__] me
that's what I kind of feel like the
weird thing though is you feel like when
you're in it you feel good after the
first two minutes you feel like I was
gonna swim in there
yeah like if a seal would have swam up
or like oh hey
I feel like it would have been very we
say our separate
the two wise paths yeah
dude there's nothing I don't think
is there anything
is there anything more homo uh
homoerotic than two men and one ice bath
together
dude do you think anyone okay this is a
weird question
do you think it's possible physically
possible after 10 minutes be in the ice
bath to get an erection
in it you have to can't leave oh no way
no way you can say anything could happen
like any type of visual mental
simulation you need
wow that's a great that would be almost
better I feel like than Dana White slap
fight I think you know watching that
like it had an underwater cam first of
Pop yeah
and we're just the refs on the side
but it would have to be a clear tank you
know and also I think you'd have to get
a certain like
it'd be so hard to get it all the way to
the top
I don't know sorry we were to send these
ice baths so I got these blue cube ice
baths they sent me one a while back and
then they sent another one
um and they're awesome I've just never
and now you can sit two men facing each
other in them and this is the first time
I've ever done anything like that
so thank you dude you're welcome thank
you for having me yeah thank you for
having me I uh and so we're yeah it's
just we're both really we just got out
I've been trying to convince you dude
we've been hanging out I hope this
podcast doesn't suck because we've been
hanging out and talking for literally
the last five those six days yeah
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday Monday
today's Tuesday oh man so we've been
together for a week talking so this is
the longest relationship I've been in
probably five years
but I've been trying to get you to get
in the ice bath with me
in Florida where it makes sense yeah
it's not 32 degrees when you get out
that's true man we got out and it was
all yeah it was like just yeah I'm
trying to think of what it does it
definitely I was just talking about this
with George Kittle it really heightened
it's like you don't want to do it it
changed my whole moment though my whole
Energy's kind of changed now good or bad
I think good a little while ago I was
feeling a little bit overwhelmed I'd
done a little bit of vaping you know I
was feeling like [__] was going south
and now I feel a little different yeah
you're in your cabinet eating on those
cookies well yeah I was trying to get my
my blood sugar is not very good right
now I think my blood sugar was either
down or up
give it a cookie uh did we went hunting
man that was that was crazy kind of I
feel like that was interesting I guess I
mean there's the only two things I ever
say that thing's on so I say sometimes I
say they're insane oh yeah it was an
insane trip well that was the last I
think the last time I was on here with
you
we were like we're gonna see each other
at hunting well that's true and then it
got kicked down the road because I went
to the hospital oh yeah it would be a
lot about it I didn't lie I just you
guys hit me with that stuff on the
airplane where you guys surprised me you
and uh William Compton so you told me to
pull you told me to kill myself I say
that really exactly I said don't be a
[__] I said don't get all like the
hospitals were that was during a heavy
covet I feel like and there was a lot of
like they were getting people hooked up
to ventilators dude I was on a
ventilator and you told me to pull the
plug okay
take them training wheels off and
[__] long up homie I was I was under
I had an infection in my throat
okay which is a I'm not gonna say okay
we get it understood got it so it
happens I don't know okay I go in and
they put me under anesthesia and I go on
a ventilator they basically didn't give
me a choice they're like you wanted that
or you want a trach it's like I'll take
the ventilator a trick is that the thing
we have to be like this yeah it's like
I'll take the ventilator yeah so what
would you say to people who say
and then uh
[Laughter]
that'd be the craziest if you have one
of those smokers things like what would
you say to people they are you the
throat goat
and so anyways
I'm on this ventilator and they have my
arms strapped down
and I'm on anesthesia like on all the
drugs you know the drugs the drugs I was
on all of them
I'm [__] strapped down the only thing
they don't want me to do is pull out my
ventilator
and you send me a voice message my mom's
like Oh Theo sent you something you want
to hear they're trying to cheer me up
yeah she hits play and it's like quit
being a [__] pull that [__] out walk
out like a man
sorry man I've been watching some David
Goggins videos I think
I was trying to bring you back dude they
had you on a [__] ventilator you got
a sore throat that was during code where
people were dying you know how many P
old people and kind of I don't want to
say like thicker people but you know
from Nashville yeah from Nashville yeah
it's a lot of thickens out here yeah do
you know what's the craziest part about
this story I lived at the time I moved
since but I lived five minutes from the
Nashville hospital in five excuse me
from Vanderbilt okay and five minutes
from the other hospital that's in
Nashville and I'm gonna throw it under
the bus because they did a good job with
me
and I chose
the other Hospital over Vanderbilt wow
really because Vanderbilt's like an
esteemed place I think I think it's like
one of the best in the country yeah and
he chose what the other one the other
ones I think a Chick-fil-A it was
honestly it was not joking it was a
seven minute ride on Uber to Vanderbilt
in five minutes so I was like
gotta save this time dude yeah let's
take a few minutes here you're on a
trick that are you in a full body cast
bro for a sore throat they were doing
some stuff to you it seemed like I don't
know I think I just wanted you to I was
people were dying dude and then you said
you guys said you did you know I got
that text on that airplane and that's
when Will Compton said that you died
yeah so we got up when I got out Will
Compton comes and visits me for in the
hospital and
I told him what happened my family's
telling me what happened because it was
funny afterwards they I think it scared
them in the moment and uh he's like
we'll send a video Let's Tell Theo you
died tell Theo you did it and you died
so he texted you and he was like
dude did you hear what happened to Caleb
and you hit him back right away you're
like what happened
and he was like he passed away
and then he immediately took a photo of
me doing like this in my little gown but
then you're on a plane so the photo
didn't come in the photo didn't come
yeah and he's like I'm absolutely gutted
that's what he said with the photo I
guess and so that's all I got and then
that Wi-Fi kept cutting in and out yeah
man I remember I was I was literally
crying in my seat and then some there
was like a
I don't want to say a gay guy that was
in there but some guy kept like like you
want to say it all right okay
there was a guy in there who didn't mind
I think being around other naked men
specifically the back side of them okay
and I'll say this that he uh for some
reason I think when I was kind of teared
up and stuff it gave him like an
opportunity to like
yeah like I'm a slip into this fragile
boy right here but I bucked up and kept
it together yeah and then when I landed
I found out that it was a joke and you
were still alive so you you and Wilson
have beef
I mean I would say I'm not super fond of
somebody that's gonna first of all not
even fake their own at least fake your
own death yeah don't throw me under the
bus under the grave
so I think that you know and they run
they have like a show I don't know what
it's called but they do it it's uh
yeah
it's like but it's like they're on a
short they're on like a little butt or
with the tall guy yeah yeah the other
guy played football here Taylor and he's
and you know they're on a sh I mean
first of all they're on a little bus
which is like
not saying that's where they belong
short bus it's a short bus they're on
they're on a short bus and uh
yeah I would look I wouldn't I would say
this would you fight him if you saw him
I don't know if it would be on site but
I think if I if somebody arranged
something I would say that do you think
you and I could beat them in a fight
somewhere like a
I don't know if like rough and ratty
that barstolder but or something do we
have guns
I think maybe one gun is hidden in the
ring somewhere
oh first man to the gun no if it's equal
opportunity for the gun I don't think we
win really but if we have them if we
bring guns
they think it's equipped to news like
right in the middle and it starts when
we pull out goes and kill their ass
yeah yeah I mean I don't I mean yeah
like Compton I think his eyesight's real
bad he has CTE yes CT EFG dude I saw
that's between you guys man well look
there you they work with the same
company Taylor got some new teeth did he
really wow
so that's [__] Rich [__] dude because
his other ones look good too did they
see Will has new teeth but his other
ones didn't look as good oh really I
thought they were fine they look good
for football player but you could make
the argument once you come out of
football it made sense Taylor had good
looking teeth yeah
but he's had too much money he's like I
guess I'll get some new ones yeah that's
crazy when people just get extra teeth
and what do you do with your old teeth
you just keep them somewhere I guess do
the new teeth go over your old teeth
oh I don't know like a five like a like
a nickel package I don't know if you're
running in his mouth I don't know I
really don't know he's running like a
4-3 line in his mouth I don't know they
had um
I remember there was this homeless dude
and he he kept all his teeth in his
pocket and when he would smile he so he
didn't have any teeth left when he would
smile he would just go like this
and show you his teeth in his hand so he
would smile like with his mouth and he
would get him out and [__]
[Laughter]
and show you all of them
so you gotta respect that kind of [__]
dude I'm still sure yeah I wouldn't say
I got beef with him but I'll just say
this if somebody wants to [__]
put some meat on the grill I'll [__]
watch it cook in front of them boys
you know
I mean I like both you guys that's
insane to hear it's it's sad to hear
that you guys have that kind of
relationship but
I mean it sounds like Will's kind of
done some stuff to you specifically will
and Taylor's probably been around in the
area
yeah
and it's not the good stuff that he's
done so until you understand faking
injuries I think to get his contract
money still
do you I mean someone's got to pay for
the teeth
you want to play he lost 40 pounds look
I was saying this I'm not putting a
bounty out on Taylor or anything but if
anybody rolls up with the ivory that's
in that dude's mouth all right I'll pay
you heavily for it like stealing
somebody's chain yeah you wear it on a
podcast you wear his teeth on the
podcast
crazy dude one time I went on Safari and
um
oh we did some comedy shows in South
Africa and went on Safari there and a
guys to this like guy that was his
family had owned a diamond mine right so
they were like
I'm not gonna say they were like they
had
slaves or whatever right but I'ma say
that they anybody that owns a diamond
mine is
um they're they've done some stuff or
whatever so they took us to their land
and they had all the animals like
everything they had all the uh
rhinoceros
um
um giraffes uh everything everything
could have and we got to see all of them
right it was crazy you're driving around
like tons of Acres you got to see all
the animals and then two weeks later
they sent us an email it was like some
poachers had showed up and they had the
Rhinos when their noses were cut off
the ivory was gone so people came in
illegally and killed off with a chainsaw
they're like they just some some guy
showed up with chainsaws and just well
dude that happened this do you know that
happened this weekend on our hunting
trip
uh-uh there's poachers that came in and
the guy shot at him oh yeah that's right
shot over him I don't know what we're
allowed to say or what we're supposed to
say
yeah well we went turkey hunting she got
shot at you know
but I think yeah we went turkey hunting
this weekend
and uh we went with Michael Waddell and
so you bring up a picture of Michael
Waddell there Riley Mao
back there beating off huh I know I
don't know if he's that guy really let's
get to a picture there Michael Waddell
bro
that's Mikhail Whittle okay
that is not how you [__] spell
oh
no why the hell w this guy
this guy looks like a [__] nut sack
sorry to say that he don't think a full
one but he looks like a couple parts of
it kind of put together
there you go
nope damn
it oh boy w-a-d-d-e-l-l
a
there we go
we went out there with Michael Waddell
and now this dude hates turkeys is that
okay there's the Osama Bin Laden the
turkeys dude yeah yeah he's Osama
Butterball lot dude this guy so we get
out there what'd you think of it man
what'd you think of the hunting well I I
thought it was uh
I thought it was 50 50 it was fifty
percent fun fifty percent very very
important it's terribly boring and 50
really fun yeah I like the parts where
the part that sings about hunting I
thought is like you you're out there and
you kind of think of it as like a chill
Vibe where you're with your boys you may
be popping a beer talking listening to
music but you can't drink because you
have guns there's no music because you
have to be quiet and then half the time
my boys you were in the car yeah yeah
well and don't throw me into the car you
were okay dude I I got a turkey
and you were in the car well let's tell
everybody exactly what happened so first
of all we go out there all right and you
set up you bring like these little
tricks and stuff you bring like little
like fans that are like uh camouflage
little and you're like just geisha girl
and out there in the field like trying
to hide behind this fan
and you kind of set like you go set up
and you hide somewhere and Michael's
also like to set it up like the number
one turkey hunter in the
yeah guest world oh yeah this guy could
yeah I mean this guy could just shoot an
arrow into the air and it would land in
a turkey he's won like a competition of
turkey calling Nationals yeah he was
like yeah he's like one of the best
turkey callers ever so he's got that uh
he's got that verbal on him you know
he's definitely
he's I mean he's a uh he's like the
Pavarotti of turkey turkey callers
so he gets out there so you kind of
setting up and then he's to he's like in
the distance he's like uh
listen
do it see if he can do it
yeah
he gave me the thing I wish I brought it
we could call it we could have used it I
know it showed for real the funniest
thing is he'll be like all right
everyone be real calm these guys eat
they eat ants and dirt for they can see
every Speck of dirt it's what they eat
for a full-time job yeah they eat
spiders buddy so if they can see that
they can see you and then they have
amazing eyesight that's the thing you
have to sneak up on so we're all sitting
dead still because he's telling us and
then I mean mommy he's running through
the field
sure so he's a fake turkey and he holds
a fake turkey in front of him I can't
see him because he's hiding on this fake
turkey that's about this big
he's holding in front of him
like an invisibility cloak yeah yeah we
had like Five Guys hiding behind a
little bitty face like it was crazy you
want to be ready for Springtime and you
want your mealing to be ready
you want your dinner table to be
um
you want it to be have dinners on it
meals look at that that guy's got a meal
in him look how happy he is look at his
family they're all milled up and they're
feeling joyous
Factor can help America's number one
ready to eat meal kit God they make good
meals I'll tell you it
get nutritious Chef prepared meals
delivered straight to your door leaving
you time and energy to tackle everything
on your to-do list do the other stuff
the swim lessons the guitar lessons or
even just a family if you want to do a
uh if your family wants to do a dang
um
what's it called when you get something
out of them
it's called Uh
uh x uh
uh
exorcism they'll help
you'll have time for it Factor has
delicious flavor-packed meals choose
from keto vegan and veggie calorie smart
and Protein Plus options on the menu
each week
34 Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly options
enjoy meals for any time of day with
breakfast options like egg bites
smoothies and more
plus replenish your supply with an
assortment of 45 plus add-ons they got
all types of snacks for you they'll do
it
had to factor meals.com
Theo 50 the numbers five zero and use
code theo50 to get 50 off your first box
that's code Theo 50 at factormeals.com
Theo five zero to get 50 off your first
box head to factormeals.com Theo 5-0 we
often hear try it free for 30 days you
hear that a lot
and that's just enough time to try
something and then forget that you've
tried it and you get billed by that
subscription or service
before you know it you're paying for it
and for months or years probably and you
can't afford a meal or something your
child and your family's left you
with rocket money you can change that
with a few quick Taps that's right
rocket money formerly known as true bill
is a personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place
over 80 percent of the people have
subscriptions that they forgot about hmm
that's a lot
like that streaming service or that uh
that beef somebody beef mailers and
they're mailing your damn beef you got
damn you know ham hocks hanging out the
mailbox and stuff and dogs are barking
at you and everyone
well stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com
t-h-e-o that's rocketmoney.com
Theo you simply find the subscription
you don't want and press cancel and
Rocket money will cancel it for you no
more long-hold times with customer
service or tedious emailing back and
forth that's rocketmoney.com Theo
rocketmoney.com Theo
so but anyway the crazy part for me is
and first of all I'll tell you why I was
in the car so we did a couple of we did
a couple of spots where you make the
calls everything nothing showed up right
it was like waiting for like it's almost
like if you order ubereats or something
and then it just doesn't show up or
whatever the guy's lost at a certain
point it's like oh [__] it I'll just go
put something in the oven but sometimes
we would see them like it would be like
if you saw ubereats like it's got closer
house or you go outside to grab it it
kind of just creeps up and then just
drives faster yeah yeah yeah they had
all types of like so anyway so the
turkey you go out there and you make the
sounds and stuff and we couldn't get the
we didn't get them remember we didn't
get them no so we had retired for the
day the first day yeah two hours we were
out there two or three hours and we said
that's enough right at that point we all
got in the truck and we were leaving and
at that point we just drove past a bunch
of turf like we'd been in the woods
looking for turkeys well Dee he was like
I saw some gobblers over there yeah so
there's another guy that was with us and
he's like uh I guess he's like a land
man you know he kind of is like a
you know part man part myth he kind of
hangs out at the camp you know this
fellow named d e was his name
and that's not a full I guess it's not a
whole name but it's he gives you half of
it you know what I'm saying he ain't he
keeps his cards because you kept saying
dyslexic ad I don't know what it stood
for I thought it was Ed but he had the
letters tangled up but uh so we get out
there and then we're riding off and d e
goes I think I think I seen a couple
gobblers okay and uh so gobblers are
turkeys I guess right and so there's
always everybody saying oh there's a
couple gobblers right around that bend
over there it's a buzzword for sure
and so it's like I say it's Synergy in a
business meeting
yeah or saying Zeitgeist people always
say oh it's in the Zeitgeist you know
um so anyway somebody pop somebody's
like oh Supple solve a couple gobblers
next you know we drive past like a bunch
of turkeys and they were like I guess
they were like on break or whatever
because I guess the turkeys are like out
like trying to hide from us and then
they all take a break anyway we get we
we went we couldn't find any turkeys
that morning so we're leaving and
there's a bunch of turkeys just like
they're like resting their legs on the
side of the road some of them are
sitting in ice tubs they're all like
it's behind the scenes we're driving
through like behind the scenes BTS yeah
yeah turkey BTS so they're like all
right let's go get one of these
gallblers all right so they got these
guys are like all right we're gonna go
get one
cause Michael Waddell does not like he
don't let a turkey live he don't want to
let a turkey live no he is when he locks
in on a bird he locks in on a bird and
he's very very very nice and very very
charismatic to people but he's that you
can see does have that switch oh it
[__] switches after three hours we're
like maybe let's go back and get some
breakfast because we've been up since 4
40 in the morning and he was maybe we
stay over here yeah killing his [__]
turkeys okay dude we'll stay around for
another minute yeah dude he won't I mean
if you even [__] mention Thanksgiving
he'll just [__] come on you yeah you
keep on saying all these turkeys you
want to do is [__] fight and I was
like yeah
so anyway they we parked the truck you
guys get out and go back into some woods
and come back a few minutes later with
uh
well what happened
dude the turkey walked up on us like I
mean this sounds crazy it was probably
seven yards away from me
but dude what are you gonna do like we
have been waiting all day we go out
there we drive all the way to Immokalee
Florida Which is far for everyone we're
doing a hunting trip we've been planning
it for six months
we're wearing camo woke up at 4 40 in
the morning yeah I'm holding a gun we're
looking for turkeys and I see one seven
yards away what am I supposed to do dude
get the rifle down yeah I don't know now
look man you guys went and did it for me
it was just like we'd done it we're
leaving we see a bunch of turkey talking
playing like they were playing like
badminton on the side of the road so
then it's like all right let's go kill
one of these bastards like oh y'all
someone threw me a peace sign
yeah yeah they're not yeah it was like
they they seemed to it was like I don't
know I felt like the hunt had kind of
ended a little bit Yeah it had
um and then also the thing about turkeys
is dude these turkeys are they're two
years old bro
well they're fully mature
that's what he told me I don't really
know but he said two years old is fully
mature turkey he's ready to die that's
what he said
bikini bite so he can serve his country
with a kid would buy a beer is what I'm
asking yeah okay but I just felt that
was the part for me was a little sick
like if like what if it was a
two-year-old kid out there and you're
hiding in the distance right making
sounds you know like oh give me that
back you know or no it's nap time you
start making [__] and he comes over and
then you just shoot him with a [__]
gun
foreign
that's the part for me that wasn't
adding up man it was like you do all
this trickery to get them to come over
and then they're only two years
deceptive it's a deceptive business yeah
and then you literally blow them you
have a blue blue birds brains out
yeah it was there was some sad parts to
it yeah also dude I shot that rifle the
whole time my only concern it was not a
rifles a shotgun the only concern I had
because I think that was the only time
in my life I've ever shot a shotgun I
never shot a shotgun oh wow think of one
time that I've done it and my only
concern was I had shot other guns I like
the range or whatever and I was thinking
every time I got earplugs I was like is
this gonna be loud like don't we need
earplugs and I was like no no no you're
good
did I shot that thing dude it sounded
like a bomb without I was like
for like three hours the next day we
went back I wouldn't even hold a gun he
was hurting so bad when you're in a hall
of the gun like these guys are insane
and I said it to him like oh yeah we I
was like we can't even really hear that
good anymore I was like he probably
can't hear me right now and he literally
said he literally said what
oh we're gonna get some gobblers yeah it
was loud that's how I already described
it was loud but we ate him so I think
that makes it like oh they cooked it up
immediately and now look though I mean
it was a great experience it was awesome
it was like
it was interesting you know I didn't
know what it was going to be like you
know I mean you go out there you kind of
set up
I think I I've always want to fight
something hand to hand
so I think it would to me it seemed like
if I got a blade on me or a sword even I
would go out there and fight a turkey
but I think you know I think the little
bit of like let me hide behind this tree
yeah and make a sound of another you
know yeah young animal and we didn't say
this but the sound is like
so it's basically a horny bird yeah like
we're supposed to be a hen we're
pretending to be a hen right trying to
seduce a horny uh Turkey right that's
like say you're at a rest area right and
you go in the there's some dude out
there smoking against the wall right
he's out there just smoking a cigarette
and you go inside the men's restroom or
the women's right and the window he's
smoking right outside of a window that
where you can inside of the restroom now
and you're like oh come on come on in
here and get this Cooter baby you know
come on in here and uh
and uh just slide up on up in this slick
wallet you know you say [__] like that
right yeah
and at first he's thinking oh that's
some [__] in there then they really
keep puffing his [__] Winston out
there yeah and then finally you're just
like you just start yelling like Oh Come
and just snack on these titty nipples
you know and finally he put that sticker
out he's like all right enough yeah and
then right when he comes in
wow yeah you [__] blow his brains
yeah I would have liked to have got one
I would go again and do it
um I think who you take and who you go
with is definitely one of the best
things like your buddy Cole Holcomb came
with us
um and that was really interesting uh it
was fun the most fun to me about the
whole trip though is by far just the
in-betweens of the hunting yeah like
going back we went on a walk it was fun
we ate we had good food we had a guy
come over tell us funny stories yeah
this guy IRA Dean came over from this
band trick pony he came over and was
telling us there's a lot of stories uh
he used to live with Johnny Cash and he
told us a lot of stories about that
um yeah yeah and it's just beautiful
you're out there wearing like the
Florida like not the Everglades not
really where it's swampy but where it's
like it just is
um kind of like
maybe High plane swamp no it's just not
wet really not wet at all yeah a lot of
alligators we saw tons of animals we saw
some uh we saw some deers we saw you
saying you saw some things trying to act
like deers it seemed like everyone was
trying to act for us everyone's put on a
show for us it was like de and all then
they were cooking good for us they put
us up and even the animals sometimes
they seem like they were trying to do a
show for us yeah well deers always act
like every time a deer stops it like
acts like it's like auditioning like
it's like on a photo shoot you know like
every deer even if it's like 60 yards
away it's just like
you know it always just kind of like
stop and stare it's almost like they're
modeling or something you know
um and it's they were supposed to have
ostrich out there that was one of the
big selling points for me is you guys
can come out here and you know gun down
on a couple stretch out here
um
and I don't know if our ostrich's like
trans birds or something they're very
I don't know do that I mean they I don't
know where they fall I don't know where
they fall I don't know that that was a
true thing that they were supposed to be
out there though yeah I think that was
an email the original email is that
there was a couple stretch out there we
could
pop off on but I'm just glad you did get
to shoot those little baby hogs or at
least shoot at them or I mean I'm not
glad that you chose to shoot at them but
that you just got to shoot a gun yeah
yeah shooting the gun was fun I wish
we'd spend more time shooting it even
just back at the camp yeah it did make
me want to buy a gun my biggest takeaway
from the whole thing was like you kind
of wonder how you're gonna feel if
you're this is my first time turkey
hunting
for how you're gonna feel to like
take another life because that's like a
serious thing it's like take another
life
and I was like am I going to feel
horrible afterwards or is it going to be
like no big deal and to me
it kind of was like because we ate it
and it was like kind of like why we're
out there it wasn't a big deal to me it
was a big deal but I was like sad yeah
does that make sense yeah yeah I was
wondering did that kind of break yeah
did you like when you got home or you're
like man I was wondering if I was gonna
feel like that but I didn't feel like
that yeah yeah well I think nature alone
nature they kill each other there's a
food chain right it's like they're not
nature you know animals don't wake up in
the morning be like Oh I'm not gonna
kill another animal funny yeah and also
in the back of my head my dude I get
turkey Toms all the time I get turkey
time from Jimmy John's two times three
times a week how am I gonna be out here
feeling bad for doing like a dead
turkey's like dude I'm killing more
turkeys every week at home
some hot peppers dude on wheat bread oh
yeah oh that's good I love a turkey time
yeah so that yeah that's a part of it
man it's like these are this is what's
you know you can't be eating it but then
be upset that it gets killed just
because you're not the one killing it
yeah almost like it's kind of bad maybe
better to go hunt it at least we went
out hunted it killed it we did
everything the right way and we cooked
it up we ate the whole bird I got the
feathers at my house there's a big slab
of meat so attached to him I don't know
if that's supposed to be there I've been
putting salt on it you saw that one that
was in my house on the floor oh yeah
still some meat on there it's been
putting salt on it to make it the stint
go away chew that [__] off that's a
[__] nugget son yeah but I felt good
about the whole thing and I I mean
Michael's awesome and I would go back
I'll go back
there I would you would yep if we went
back yeah if it was just a good group
this guy Cohen was there he was the
camera guy and also just a hunter
so yeah this isn't fast I think
the I was just so fascinated as to I
didn't know people were so fascinated
about turkeys
there seemed a lot more to learn that we
didn't learn and also the other thing is
I think probably a lot of the enjoyment
people get from it is Michael kind of
did everything for us um like we just
sat there which I'm glad he did because
we would have not got any we weren't we
didn't get any turkeys as it was right
with the best turkey guy like if we just
did it we would have got nothing but he
did do all the hard work he would he was
running around doing all this [__] so
yeah we were just sitting there with the
guns yeah he wanted to make it he made
it as easy on us as possible I think if
you got to do a grenade or you got to do
like a little like a lamb like a thing
they step on the landmine and you lay it
out there some of that I would have
enjoyed a little uh as well I think or
also you know I've always wanted to
fight a pig just with a knife that's
always been one of my goals the dreams
are yeah yeah oh to jump out of a
chopper or something and [__] get a
pig like that
that to me I just it's just the turkeys
don't have anyone hunting on their
behalf you're out there and you know no
one's gonna kill you
right it would be cool if the turkeys
had a couple weapons too like say if
there was a turkey say if Pita they're
like hey instead of just bitching about
animals over here with some poster board
every now and then yeah uh we are going
to go out in the morning on behalf of
the animals and set a couple of
landmines out maybe or you just know
that every day no matter where you are
across the world you're hunting every
single day after their shift outside of
Canadian goose in New York City they're
going to take all those protesters put
them in a helicopter and drop them with
machine guns at one of the one of the
hunting sites you don't know if it's
gonna be your Hunting site but that day
they could show up with machine guns and
murder your ass just give you like some
type of edge like some type of we're
just sitting out there kind of I mean as
you kind of go through periods of being
bored a little bit oh and you can shoot
anything else that's going to run by
that's another problem I feel like at a
certain point if you like when we didn't
see any turkeys that second day that's
when we started popping off on this pig
so it was like it's almost like anything
else that shows up is gonna get gun down
yeah so but it was uh yeah I just I
I don't know I mean it was it was cool
you know I'd had a long week so I was
also looking to kind of rest and stuff
so but it was good man I'm glad that we
went same yeah I would definitely go
again I didn't know I didn't know you
would go again I would go again if Cole
went with us too that was fun it's
totally about the group you go with 100
sitting around telling the stories
laughing all that was fun she even
sharing in the same room was fun like so
when else do you get to do that as an
adult it's like you're back at like
summer camp or something you know people
stay up they're just joking around at
night yeah uh
you know people are snoring people are
people are some people are snoring out
of their butt
there's just a lot going on out there
dude you can't wake up in the middle of
night you you like say like little words
and they're all just like super
disappointed you'd be like you're you
were sleep talking about you just be
like oh man
[Laughter]
man ah crap
what happened
I was just disappointed in my sleep I
probably was at Hamilton or something oh
you keep saying ah
yeah I was probably watching the Oscars
and then call my buddy his phone like it
was like middle of the night somehow he
turned over and his phone went on the
floor he went oh damn like you had just
been awake all day
it was fun it was really fun yeah you
guys both snored though and I don't
think I snored I was sleeping if I did
well
okay good yeah lucky you dude I didn't
hear it
um I turn on that white noise what else
is dude White Noise I've always White
Noise should just be like somebody just
like helping their kid with homework I
was just like things that white people
do you know
making a bundt cake
it's just an older couple listening to
Willie Nelson on their front porch
[Laughter]
oh man what else dude good to see you
again man it's fun yeah I haven't seen
you since
all week every day that's what I'm
saying I was like damn dude I hope we
have something to talk about I guess we
always something to talk about yeah what
was um
your season's wrapped first Sunday
conversation yeah yeah we do like
so it's Sunday conversation started as
a segment on our pro football show like
Sunday conversations CBS countdown or
whatever their NFL show is and we just
added it Sunday conversation Glennie
balls eats a ice cream sundae that was
just the idea a little segment for our
show so a random football season so for
the first three years we've done we've
done three years now three seasons we
just ran it during football but now I
feel like it's going to take on its life
of its own a little bit where I'm not
sure if people I don't think people like
do the math in their heads it's like oh
this is a football show mainly because
we never talk about football yeah and
the people who are on are pretty much
never football players so it's not a
football show really and so now I'm just
thinking about like is do we really have
to do it like because it's like 25 weeks
or something football
like 25 weeks in a row of doing that
show I travel to the guests to make it
easier on booking so like you know it's
if you they have to come to
where I live in you know Del Rey or if I
was in Nashville they had to come to
Nashville it makes a lot harder so I
traveled to the guests which is a lot
yeah and I wonder if the show would be
better a better quality show if we can
focus on the bookings get really good
bookings and just go to them knock them
out and spend really good time on the
edits and stuff
and then not have to worry about being
during only football season 25 weeks in
a row if we just do it year round
sorry whenever we get a good opportunity
to do it right so not so maybe just like
it could be every two weeks or every
three weeks just whatever it could be
back to back I don't know maybe people
will hate that I don't know there is
something to being the same time every
week people can wake up to it that
definitely some to it but I'm kind of
playing with the idea of just starting
to release them as we can get them
but I don't know I mean that could be a
dumb idea I haven't tried it yet that's
kind of the direction I see it going
it's is it nice though to have like that
break it's like you have the time where
you don't have to go it's like you can
know okay for this 12 weeks of my life
I'm gonna go and capture episodes I do
like that about football season because
I think about Like This Is My Season
but the problem is is like get out now
so now I'm like in off season but I have
a job like it's not off season like I
still have to be doing stuff what are
you doing you mean like I like like I
shouldn't I like I work for a company
like they should I should be doing stuff
still like I can't just like all right
tell foot next football year like I'll
be training until then like I take off
like a week or something like I should
still be doing stuff yeah and so and I
am we're doing some different stuff and
me and you did some this morning but
um
I think that going away from just being
intense about it I do like that though I
think it's a good point like it is fun
to focus in on something for a long time
but just and also like things get played
out too if you don't it's already been
we've already been doing it a long time
and so I'm I'm not worried about it
getting played out but I think to avoid
it getting played out like really making
the episode's really good and really
quality and I think that takes a little
bit more like thought and time than just
like really every week just ramping them
out ramping them out right but you've
had some I mean you've had amazing
guests you've had uh how was that Drake
what was that Drake experience like
going there did you go to his house yeah
oh wow yeah and does he have like how
many front doors does he have I feel
like he'd have like a front door and
then if you're they let like somebody
lets you into that one but it's not even
him and you get closer and closer and
finally he lets you in like a real yeah
we were in his house for probably like
probably 90 minutes or two hours before
I even saw him oh really yeah
wow yeah it was an insane awesome
experience he's my favorite artist ever
wow ever so like girl because he's been
around making like great music for 15
years
since I was in high school and they say
that's your most like your favorite
music of your life is going to be the
music that you heard when you're in high
school really they say that I don't know
they are yeah
probably some gobblers but you know like
he just been like that guy for forever I
mean I grew up Lil Wayne was the best
Lil Wayne was like the goat and he was
the inspiration I think even for Drake
it's obviously Jake says it but um so
like Lil Wayne and Drake those are the
two guys and so 15 years down the line
or whatever 10 years down the line
um to be able to like meet him and like
go to his house and like me just like
who answered the door when you got there
not Drake huh no no no he has a dude his
security is insane good luck dude I
would like to see the [__] busting
boys try to to run up with their teeth
and there was some guns trying to get
that Drake dude good luck dude there's
so many he has the most security you
ever seen security uh imagine more wow
okay you're not getting to this guy no
chance but uh damn he was awesome I mean
and was there some chicks there with the
breasts or whatever I mean I'm sure they
were I didn't see him they kind of kept
us in the gym oh really yeah like there
was a gym and it was like you gotta use
the bathroom like you really gotta go
you can go but like you guys need to
stay in the gym oh but otherwise pee
before you pee when you leave yeah yeah
but he was awesome like
and it's I was a little worried about it
because
he is kind of like in my eyes like this
Larger than Life thing that I really
love like I love his music and so like
you get worse like if I'm am I gonna
meet him is he going to ruin his music
for me
yeah you know what I'm saying oh totally
like is he gonna be kind of a dick or oh
yeah Michael Landon was supposed to come
to our town one time and meet people
and my mom was all excited and
everything and then he didn't show up or
something
or is I don't know what happened it
ruins I've had that happen to me before
so I was worried about it but no 10 like
10 of 10 experience he could not have
been
and he was super like into it too like
before the episode he was like he he
wanted to do it like okay he was into
the idea he was throwing ideas out like
he wanted to put a son in it like we
didn't he was like do you think it'd be
funny if we put a dog if he opened up
with Adonis which is his son's name like
would it be funny if everyone thinks
it's gonna be me and then it's just
Adonis in there and is his son walk into
the room does someone care bring his son
to the room like on a little thing or
like a little palette or something like
how does I just I picture like somebody
carrying his son and a pillow and
setting him down in the room he was
watching like his little juice box he's
so swaggy
his son's gonna be like I don't I wonder
what will happen because I don't mean
like Michael Jordan's Michael Jordan's
sons they played basketball LeBron's
Sons played basketball
Drake's on like is he gonna be a rapper
or is he just gonna be he's going to be
famous just by nature of people are
going to know who he is right just by
nature of his dad
like he has star qualities for sure just
by talking to him I mean that's crazy to
say like five years old he's like that
two-year-old turkey dude but uh
I don't know he was he was great I mean
it's hard to like comment on a kid but
he was I mean he was just a
five-year-old like a pure little five
year old wasn't like jaded or anything
yet like you still talking about
five-year-old stuff he was he's talking
about like kids in his class who could
read he's like I can't read yet but
they've got some nerds in my class who
can read yeah
[__] him
damn dude and what about who else was
thinking about oh what's something that
people don't know about that has Bullock
eye like do people what is like
I don't think enough people comprehend
that he's Muslim he's like super
religious oh really and so now what does
that mean does he like when the sun
comes out he has to be in a certain
position what is what all
like what is he doing
he's not talking to women he's not
photographing with women
he's not in bars like he's not he's in
the United States for the first time
right now he has his visa for the first
time wow so he's in Vegas and I'm sure
like I talked to his people a little bit
I'm sure that he could probably pick up
like
insane insane bags just go to like the
win nightclub or whatever and just kind
of get held up a little bit maybe punts
Steve Aoki in the face or something and
get like a million bucks oh he can't do
it he can't do it why he's Muslim so
like he can't be around alcohol it can't
be oh and he's serious about it he's
like a serious dude he's 19.
so he's like fully developed brain
very serious about life serious about
being Muslim he's funny he's like I got
a good sense of humor he like likes that
fun but he's like uh
he's he's a devout religious person I
don't think people realize that and do
they put him on a little rug and stuff
every like hour and a half or how does
that work dude it's hilarious actually
what happens is girls who come up to him
he's the most famous person I've ever
been around ever and just like doing
this job for however long
interviewing people who are like
celebrities and stuff you you meet you
run into people you hang out with people
who are like famous and you see people
who have crazy followings
hezboola is by far the most famous
person I've ever ever seen
when he walks through a place it's like
the whole room just like
just come in on him everyone's trying to
take pictures everyone's like wanting to
get punched in the face by him
and I think it's because he looks even
if you don't know who he is just by the
look of him you're like that guy
there's something special about that guy
because when I first saw him I thought
he was like a dwarf
like a dwarf size you know like this
tall yeah but he's three feet he's one
football yard he's This Tall oh he's got
all that body and Charisma packed into
this size damn it's like a baby Snicker
yeah
Bro think about this think about a kid
like this big you just like hold him
that's a gobbler huh now think about
this what if you hid behind a like a
bench in the mall and made some Muslim
sounds and then when he came around the
bed she blew around that's insane it
seems insane doesn't it there's some
people in Immokalee who love to do that
to a Muslim
dude
yeah definitely you don't have to drive
far around that hear the n-word like you
could just he could be downwind of
anybody in that area you will catch it
you know
oh there he is right there oh look you
know and he really is a handsome guy
isn't he let's see him with his hair
blowing out he got a uh he got his hair
blown out there for a wedding or
something that fourth pitcher Riley
oh there he is right there oh he's a
solid dude and he hangs out he's from
this little village in Russia and he
hangs out with all his friends from his
village and that's his team and they're
all into UFC you know I don't know
anything about UFC really but I think
they have like three or four of the top
fighters are from his village a small
village in Russia
Dagestan Dagestan yeah and so he's like
boys with all those guys like who's it
khabib yeah
they might have the last same last name
I'm not sure
yeah let's look up house bula's last
name Mago Madoff
but is it normal made of
it's Mago made of so it's not nurmago
made of I think you have to earn the
nerve
that the first question is hasbul a baby
he uh
genetic disorder called childlike Trails
no that's not what that says that causes
childlike traits sorry what uh no what's
crazy is the soccer player another thing
I don't support I don't know about
um
what is it it's maybe messy one of these
top guys
has had the same exact thing Hezbollah
has I think to my knowledge it's like a
treatable pretty very treatable disease
but you have to have the treatments when
you're young and he wasn't able to get
him he wasn't able to get him so this
soccer player I think it's messy but it
could be someone else
had that thing they treated him they
said some HGH when you're little and
then he turns out to be like the best
soccer player of all time and then it's
just like can you get that dose damn
wow that's fascinating yeah because I
get yeah if that it's interesting this
is if you can get medicines or not
getting meds dude it's always been an
issue getting a hold of drugs uh but can
can he date women or it's not allowed
until he's married I'm not really sure
can you look up Muslim dating practices
please
I know that some some Muslims have
multiple wives
but can he even get started on his first
wife I don't know it's confusing maybe
just start with a second
I don't know dude
yeah you're right Muslim Dating Rules
five Muslim Dating Rules in Traditions
you need to know eight Muslim eight
Muslim Dating Rules and jerseys you need
to know you click on that brother
be mature and old enough to start dating
that makes sense
date with intention of finding
your partner no premarital sex there it
is baby
better stay off that gobble until you
put a ring on it
single people need chaperones wow
I think having a beard is important I'm
not joking
I think that's a big part of it you
gotta have a beard if you're a man
that sounded like a joke it's not that's
part of it I think it's a show your
manhood right yeah maybe it's
interesting I wonder if I'd be a good
Muslim or not
I don't know you ever thought about
doing it
I don't I think you have to be you have
to be born into it he can just do it so
you can did you do it yeah
would you try it
maybe I tried keto for like I guess
almost a month mm-hmm
kind of makes you smell bad though
doesn't it
which one
Keto
yeah
there's a little dose of your own
medicine there the sunshine continues to
do its thing it man it just every every
day that damn air ornament is up there
just leaving its headlights on
so our friends at Shady Rays have you
covered
that's right with premium polarized
Shades at an affordable price
Shady Rays is an independent sunglasses
company that offers a world-class
product that's just as good as any
expensive pair that I've ever worn
they have durable frames and extremely
clear optics for Outdoor Adventures
and that's not all shady Rays offers the
most insane protection in all of eyewear
every pair of sunglasses is backed by
lost and broken Replacements yep
every purchase
if you lose or break your payer even on
day one
they told us they will send you a brand
new payer no questions asked
wear your shady Rays with confidence
because they have your back long after
your purchase
if you don't love your shady Rays
exchange for a new payer or return them
for free within 30 days wow there's no
risk when you shop their team always has
your back
exclusively for our listeners Shady Rays
is giving out their best deal of the
Season go to Shady rays.com and use code
Theo for 50 off two plus pairs of
polarized sunglasses try for yourself
the shades rated 5 Stars by over 250 000
people
that's shady rays
s-h-a-d-y-r-a-y-s.com and use code Theo
for 50 off two or more pairs of
polarized sunglasses I just tried gamer
sups
it's the best alternative to traditional
energy drinks and sugar loaded beverages
gamer sups GG energy is a zero sugar
keto friendly source of caffeine that
gives you the energy you need without
worrying about a crash later
sometimes you don't want that caffeine
where you're doing well and next thing
you know you got to take a nap or you
got a dang pet a puppy or you're not
gonna make it the powder perfectly
dissolves into water and with 100
milligrams of caffeine per scoop you can
determine how much uh caffeine you want
to have for your personal energy needs
gamer Subs has lots of unique flavors
like blowhole blast emotional damage
titty milk and more a lot of these
flavors also come in caffeine free if
you're just someone who wants to stop
drinking as much sugar day to day
you can also get free samples of gamer
sups on their website but for the next
24 hours you can use code Theo Von no
spaces at checkout and you will get free
shipping as well
uh for the first 1 000 people to order
you will get a custom Theo Von sticker
claiming free samples is as easy as
clicking on the link go to
gamersupps.gg Theo Vaughn and use code
theovan to get free shipping on free
samples for the next 24 hours where you
or a friend ever injured at work
were you compensated fairly if you felt
like you should have been
it's a good question
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan
and Morgan is America's largest injury
Law Firm with over 15 billion dollars
recovered for clients Morgan and Morgan
has a proven track record of fighting to
get you full and fair compensation
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is so easy it's more like
using an app than hiring a lawyer if
you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to
forthepeople.com this past weekend or
dial pound law which is pound 529 from
your cell phone that's f-o-r
thepeople.com slash this past weekend or
pound 529 from your cell that's pound
law this is a paid advertisement
um what else has we got going on dude
he's fan yeah he's the most famous he's
like Morgan Wallen almost sheesh dude no
one's like Morgan Wallen bro his numbers
this week are in I just saw it on on
Instagram before I came up here
his album
did 420 came in 472
000 streams and I think that like the
second highest was like 70.
and the they put together like the next
nine
together like the next nine best from
country artists and they equaled or or
less than Morgans wow so it was like 70
50 50 40 30 12.
and it was less
well he's like Elvis Presley man I don't
think you realize I wonder will he be
bigger than Garth Brooks was in his
prime how big was Garth Brooks you think
I mean he was big
was you think he was the biggest by far
because I think because Garth like
adults were listening to him and chill
they were playing him like at all the
school dance he was like you know we had
that breadth of the same thing that
Morgan does you know top 50 songs in the
in the Apple thing right now he has 36
of them no way
in his albums 36 songs which also is
insane yeah 36 songs on album is
that's a lot that's more than one album
yeah that's albums I mean look how many
words can you find that rhyme with
Silverado
uh but he mastered it man it's good too
man it's like At first you're like oh I
don't know if I'll love that song and
then three days later you're like just
planning on repeat I haven't took it off
last night you lit the lick it talk wait
do it do it in my trick voice
[Laughter]
dude everybody's like even Chinese
people are listening that's what I said
I said who's listening to this dude who
are 429 000 people who is that
like who who is listening to Morgan wall
how are there that many people who even
have access to like Dee probably would
have liked them but there's no way he
has access to
he doesn't have Spotify dude yeah he
ain't getting any Wi-Fi out there dude
yeah no sir I mean he'll Frisk you for
some news right when we see him you know
what did you guys talk about you guys
are in the car for like 40 minutes well
yeah when I when I went to set in the
car uh
it was just me and de in there wait
describe what he looked like just do
like a if you had to describe him D I
would say he's kind of a he probably
64 60
to 66.
he's had a good bit of sun on him the
son knows him you know what I'm saying
the sun is [__] the sun knows him and
he knows the Sun what do you think he
wears we saw him a camo but like what do
you think he would wear if he was going
to go out for like a steak or something
steel camo yeah no doubt about it I mean
how would you how would you like
describe his like smell because you were
in the car with him for a long time oh I
think he's clean he seemed clean he
seemed put together
he seemed
what'd he say
we were talking about Adam and Eve
and uh
that was it he's kind of a Biblical man
dude he had a he he
okay so we're in we're at the house I
think you are outside yeah and I was
sitting inside and everyone had been
talking and it was kind of a situation
we were all moving around go inside
outside take a break from the
conversation go back out because you
know we're talking about some
sometimes you walk away and you come
back it is what it is and he walked in I
think he had just dropped this bomb on
you guys and he liked the reception he
got outside so he came in he's like I
gotta get out of there they're talking
about they're taught they're going way
too deep and I was like what what
they're talking about and then he just
dropped it on me too but it was kind of
a good point he was like
all right so the Bible he's like you got
Bible you got Adam yep he did it to you
too you got to eat you got their two
sons
where'd all other people come from
Big Talk how do you get the Chinese how
do you get Japanese blacks Mexicans
other people
and I was like and I was like yeah wait
how did that happen I looked up the
biblical family tree and it's it's uh
Adam
you got Adam yeah you gotta eat you got
your three sons
hey
yeah where'd you get that next gobbler
Raleigh Mal you might know Riley are you
uh I'm able to put these on real quick
Raleigh's a Biblical man aren't you
Riley I am yeah and what do you know
about that rally uh where'd they get the
other people
uh
what other people
like us
or other people between now and the
Bible like if Adam and Eve had two
children they're both men well they had
three and one of them got murdered yeah
by the other one yeah that's pretty
crazy
so how did other people get created
uh I I don't know it just happened
amen it's something I had never thought
about yeah because I was really I mean
I've come from a Christian household
just something I never thought about
that I never thought about it either man
it's interesting how do they get all the
other people
but we may not ever know
but we're here
but yeah it was interesting how many
people love Morgan wallen's Music Man
they had yeah even like Chinese people
are like you know last night we lit the
liquor talk like everybody's listening
to it
[Music]
like people you wouldn't even think man
a guy is in a coma
everybody's [__] listening
he's got the juice bro they're just
you make good music oh yeah he's got a
great voice dude
and what a hard album to follow the
dangerous was the best album ever
I think it was Brave to come out and do
an album immediately after I would have
quit dude yeah or at least on 30 30
songs yeah
like to come out after dangerous I had
to follow that up with the pressure so
high
and then my first thought I was like uh
yeah well this kind of sounds like
dangerous and I was like Danger's the
best album ever
yeah dude it's funny because even when I
heard dangerous whenever I went with
Morgan or in his band they were playing
it somebody's one of his producers
houses they were playing it the first
time I'd heard it and I was like I don't
know some of them you know and then like
a week later I was like it's the best
[__] ever you know it's funny how it
just I don't know it's hard it takes you
a little bit to get to know a song yeah
I ever told you a story about uh Luke
Combs
um I feel like I told you this before
you might have
stopped me if I've said this before but
so whenever I was uh
me and Luke went to high school together
okay he was an offensive lineman he was
a senior when I was a freshman so I
played on the varsity as a backup
quarterback and then uh he was a senior
offensive lineman so
he didn't play much and I didn't play at
all
and so we would sit and talk to each
other on the sideline just kind of oh
I've seen you guys I haven't seen y'all
but I've seen guys just like y'all on TV
it's like the guys who know they're not
going in so they're getting really
comfortable and they're really digging
in their heels and having a good
conversation like that's what we were
doing and so I always kind of was good
friends with him as much as you could be
from a freshman and a senior
and so he goes on to App State and uh my
dad died when I was really little so
when I turned 21 I was at Carolina I got
a secure Social Security so I got like I
think like I can't remember like 40 or
50 000 and just kind of hit my bank
account that gobbler yeah I got that
Goblin I had never had any money ever
and so I was just it was burning a hole
in my pocket I was like I gotta spin
this immediately I was like I had to get
rid of this money and so I hit up Luke
I you know I was like what could I do
this I want to like invest it you know
you're 21 you're like half a brain
you're trying to figure out a finance
the rest of your life make some huge
business move ask a 21 year old you know
like dude uh so I hit up Luke I was like
and he's making all these videos he's
singing at App State he's like on the
local TV I remember seeing him in the
local team was he doing well at that
point he was just he wasn't doing
anything besides he was singing like the
local bar and he had a Facebook that's
when Facebook was big and he was posting
his videos he had this incredible voice
and I was like bro you are gonna be you
could be something like you could you
could be something and hit him up I told
him that
and Chase Rice went to our high school
too and he was already doing it so we
kind of had that glimpse of you kind of
just had that glimpse of oh this could
really happen for somebody wow because
Chase had done it out of our out of our
high school and so I told Luke and I was
like man I would love to I got this
money I'm trying to blow basically
and I was like I would really like to uh
I would really like to like figure out a
situation like to invest in you in your
career dude because I think you're gonna
be like you could do something you just
need some money and he's like for what
you know but uh so anyways we're like
trying to talk about it we're like how
would it work and he's like let me send
you some songs I'm like working on and I
have the email exchange still and uh he
sends me like three songs
and I I listened to him and I've got
this like cocky 21 year old I'm not
being cocky but you know you just think
you know everything and I'm like oh well
you know I don't know I sent him back
some notes I was like I like this one
but maybe we could do this and
uh you could do this I'm financing it
bro he does whatever I want him to do
dude
uh anyway so he sent me these three
songs
long story short nothing ever happens
because it's impossible to just give
someone money and like what am I gonna
get like what if I got like 10 of his
career earnings I wouldn't be here I
know that but uh anyway so basically
fell through the cracks and I was
telling that story to somebody like uh a
couple years later I was like I'm gonna
go back and find those emails bro I went
back and by the way my notes were like
this song Maybe not it this song's
pretty good but maybe you could use a
dip bubble like an idiot don't know
anything about music never play the
instrument sang in my life and then uh
he probably thought I was an [__] he
didn't say that he probably was like
this guy's a [__] yeah I go back dude
all three records were number one really
it was like when it rains it pours it
was like his first three number ones and
it was just sent him to me I was like
yeah but um
okay okay that's all I'm saying bro
everybody's listening to that [__]
so dude you're obviously not a good joke
dude I got the older I get the more I
have zero good qualities
zero good qualities
damn dude
can you imagine that that would have
worked if I could have figured out that
business deal I was born with a baby in
my head
bro everybody is listening
tell Morgan Wallen that's all I'm
telling you bro
sheesh
that's all I'm telling you man uh
and I went to Morgan show too in uh in
Arlington you went in Arlington it was
like I think it was one of his first
stadium shows if not his first one
and it was it was one of the best shows
I've ever seen in my life so good not to
like gas it up more than we already have
but like the show itself is like an
amazing show I thought it was over like
25 times
he literally finished he did like 10
encores it was within four and a half
hours oh it's the longest show it was
still there people went home he was
still singing
yeah dude he was he's saying a different
voices dude by the end he's just up
there like okay
that's all I say about he just he goes
through it all it's a great show he's
they're playing stadiums now they're in
they just went to Australia last week
and the coolest thing is it's him Hardy
Earnest and I think Parker McCollum
so my god dude that's so fun and I've
been and all right how about this merry
[__] kill right oh no
those four guys
first of all what we're doing with the
last one
I'm gonna do that with we'll call him
okay mccallum's out yeah because I just
don't I don't know I don't know okay
um
I would marry I would marry Ernest
oh yeah
because he's blonde I feel like he's
funny I feel like he he might be like
he'll be someone you'd be happy to be
married to when you're old
right right right yeah you'd be able to
laugh and stuff your whole lives
together yeah yeah and then I will
probably kill
oh I would probably I would probably
kill Morgan
because you don't want to [__] him dude
like imagine how many people [__] him
that's true Point that's crazy I'm not
I'm not getting in that line yeah that's
true that's true yeah I'll get with
Hardy for sure and then also Morgan's uh
music has definitely put me on to Hardy
who's another awesome artist yeah who
I've been like just listened to his
songs more than probably anything else
recently
yeah I've been listening to uh
I listen a lot those guys and even
Florida Georgia Line were in my top five
last year for
uh that Spotify whatever that thing that
comes out wrapped
um and then I saw this chick Jesse
Murphy have you heard of her she's from
Huntsville Alabama dude we were at the
show and we were at the show
in Fort Worth or Arlington and so I went
to see Ernest specs he's opened up for
Morgan so I went to see the show go see
him before this thing and he's smoking
join on his bus he's got all those
people all smoking joints on the bus
he's like you want to smoke I was like
okay I smoke like took a puff of their
weed or whatever and
was literally just immediately like
you know that feeling like you're I
don't know if you've smoked weed before
but yeah you get you get to that uh like
oh like I'm I'm there like I got there
pretty fast and then we were kind of
sitting on the bus we're all kind of
looking at each other I could see in his
eyes too we're like oh wow like we're
there and then we walked off
I was like bro I don't know how I'm
gonna do this concert like we got three
hours of music I'm supposed to be out
here talking to people and I'm kind of
like
and then that's what Ernest said and
that's how I was feeling after I walked
off the bus because I don't know how I'm
gonna do this concert so I get into our
seats and me and my friend are just
saying the same thing to each other like
dude it's gonna be a long night and we
see Ernest go up on stage and perform
like dude how is he doing that dude I
can barely stand here and listen he's up
there [__] singing
he crushed too yeah I did it's a
different type of cat
yeah I'll marry him for sure
he's a bad day for love but a good day
everybody loves the music
oh man yeah bro it's a look it's an
exciting year knowing that they're gonna
be out touring knowing that there's a
possibility to go see them because it is
fun I went and saw them at uh
in nam Nashville and it was amazing it
was amazing man
um who was a tough guest to have on your
show who was there a guest you're like
man this is just
it was hectic kind of or it was tougher
we never
I would say
almost without exception everyone's been
pretty awesome
some of them are more business like some
of them are more like a lot of them are
just hangs like usually get there
whether they've seen the show or not you
know shoot it and they'll either have
already seen it and they kind of know
have a feel for who I am yeah or they
like it they like like they think it's
funny and they think like it was a good
experience and so we'll just end up
hanging out like we shot Michael Irvin
during covid and I've never met Michael
Urban he didn't know us from Adam but we
shot the video we all laughed so hard
together we ended up just hanging out on
a Friday night watching like shitty
college football like for like an hour
yeah so that's kind of how they most are
some of them are more business like some
people just they're in and out which
those are the ones that are kind of
right you don't get to know the person
as much it's a good video but like for
me I like the actual experience like
getting to meet the people and hanging
out with them so yeah I prefer those
ones but uh like even Drake We like he
he's like you guys we finished like 10
30 a night he was like what are you guys
doing for dinner and we're in Toronto
it's like a Tuesday night and there's
nothing open it's only McDonald's we're
actually planning on going like have a
celebration at McDonald's
she's like oh no it's all I'll open a
restaurant for you guys or like whatever
I'll keep it okay like I'll keep a
restaurant open for you guys you like
call some Russian we show up it's
already closed and they're just like
wow like Drake Shack it says Drake Shack
when you get there on the sun yeah he's
the man and uh what about Stephen A
Smith what was that like he was
hilarious he was he was kind of in and
out but he was he was doing like a press
tour he went on every show oh he did he
went on like every show that's ever
happened he was on like doing like local
newspapers he was like promoting his
book he was on like the women's shows
daytime talk he was like in a sitcom
series he was he did my show part of my
take so he was running through the
gauntlet
but he enjoyed it he people just like
doing stuff that's not the everyday
cookie cutter I think oh for sure I
think it's one thing that's interesting
even just about like New Media and stuff
is it shows are different that's what's
so cool about hot ones I think when it
first popped off you know
um is that it was just a different way
of having an interview it was something
he's so good interviewing too
Sean Evans yeah he's a master of you
he's a master he is like a very much
like a Sensei you know have you met him
yeah I feel like he might be the best in
like just in terms of just interviewing
somebody and getting in and researching
delivering his research and turning it
into it's not just about like I know
this extra stuff about you it's like he
takes what he's learned it forms the
audience of like what some background
stuff you didn't know and then weaves
into an interesting question that the
guest enjoys answering
because that's what makes a good show is
like people
like to be on his show I think oh you've
done his show yeah people like to do the
show because it's like he gives them
interesting things yeah think about yeah
it was cool it was it was like oh this
is fun I'm enjoying kind of thinking
about my own life here yeah I think he's
the best who is some
um what are some upcoming guests because
I know you guys do about kind of Seasons
here so what are some upcoming like
would you get Biden or Trump on you
think
I would I think they would be hilarious
and equally equally the funniest
episodes of all time yeah
I would do it if
Biden would do it and Trump would do it
and run them like what back to back
weeks so no one's like you know you live
or whatever you know whatever you're
taking a political side I don't want it
to be political at all and that's the
problem though is like I know so many
people Davis said this they poor know
who I work for at Barstool
um I think other people have said it
like I know happened to Elon Musk it's
happened to Joe Rogan it's happened to
the the dude from milk boys Steve will
do it like you just watch people kind of
get involved with something that could
even be construed as political
and then all of a sudden dude you get
you got canceled like not canceled in
terms like the fake cancel but you got
like newspaper articles being written
about how you're a terrible guy they're
digging up dirt from your past or
talking to
every person who doesn't like you ever
like they're it just it's happened to
all those guys like you really is it
really worth it for that funny moment to
like have your whole life dug up right
and especially if it seemed like if you
go after a concert if you have
conservative people on then it's
definitely more likely to happen
probably yeah for sure you know for sure
which is crazy but
yeah that just kind of is what it is
would you do it
if you want that smoke I mean I've
thought about I mean I've gotten all
like
we were thinking about trying to have
Tucker Carlson on you know and so I
think like I don't know a lot about him
you know but it's all maybe like to get
to know more about him as a person you
know
so I'll say this my uh
my grandma she watched Fox News every
night like religiously and what happened
to her she passed away she passed away
she got died she got diagnosed with
Alzheimer's and um when she got
diagnosed Alzheimer's Tucker was doing a
lot of stuff with barcel at the time
with Dave Dave was going on the show a
lot and so I knew people at Barcelona I
never met him I still have never met him
but I said I would really like to do
something nice for my grandma right now
so I asked our booking people do you
think there's any way Tucker Carlson
could like I know it's a crazy ass he's
probably busy and whatever but like
worth asking would he like make a video
for my grandma oh and he made this video
and sent to me it was like a two minute
video just being so nice she didn't
remember it all I don't think she was
but like just the fact he did this like
you know they're people too you know
it's like I know people hate him or
whatever but
talk
that was your grandmother sorry she told
me to tell you that
[Music]
no
but um yeah anyways just just like uh
for people who hate Tucker I don't know
him but don't watch a show
um and I've seen it and I I don't watch
it on purpose okay but um but it you
know nice guy or he did something nice
here at one point did something really
nice for me my family
yeah I mean I just yeah I think
sometimes I just think like I don't know
enough about politics to get where if
I'd want to get that deep someone who's
that on one side of it you know but well
that's what I do that's what happened to
Dave he interviewed Trump
and then they started coming out from
the sex tapes came out that's when you
saw all the sex tapes yes in the New
York Times writes article that's when
Business Insider writes the article
that's whenever he starts like and it
hurts his business and like you can say
like Dave I really don't think he cares
about people's opinions yeah I don't
think he cares but it hurts the business
it's not good and it hurts your
relationships
you know he has got a girlfriend and
he's got all this crazy stuff coming out
yeah so just maybe not worth it but to
answer your question I think it'd be
hilarious
yeah it'd be interesting man yeah I
think it would just be interesting to
get to know who that person is you know
the kind of the good thing is I don't
know that much about politics I've saw
my own thoughts and feelings but I don't
get into like a lot of uh
uh listening to a lot of the like the
the points of it and you know right I
just have my own thoughts and feelings
about what I think about
you know I guess living and being in a
country and
being human in the world Riley what are
some different Morgan Wallen songs pull
up the top ten right now pull up the top
country 50 right now
pull up the top fifth I mean the you can
do country but like he's all the whole
everything 50. really
so when I was doing so I had Morgan on
my Show streaming yeah when I had more
on my show they sent me like a like a
press release which I didn't use because
my questions don't like go off that but
I uh like read it over his last album
was the number one most longest
is the longest at a number one of any
album ever or something similar to that
number two was Adele
and number three was Bruce Springsteen
and Morgan Wallen was longer than them
yeah he's elf I mean he's the Elvis
Presley right now
I mean I'm excited to hear Luke's new
album too yeah because he is he is I
think that's I think if if
wallen's 1A I think he's 1B
oh Bailey Zimmerman's gonna be on that
tour with him as well
oh there you go right there last night
thinking about me thought you should
know
um
yeah I wonder who else would be a unique
guest for you to have on
maybe that guy that killed those P like
a murderer or somebody yeah you think he
could get a murderer Lewis
uh maybe BTK one of those guys or
something I would take
Jameis Winston would be my number one I
actually want Beetlejuice the most dude
how great is Beetlejuice he would be my
number one I've been trying to get him
what happened
well he apparently he like lives in
Georgia and he just says enjoy like if
you go down there you can see him like
he's in a town he like goes to the store
people know where he's at but yeah I've
beat the [__] out of him yeah dude they
would ask about anything he was like hey
your grandfather's dying like I'll [__]
him up
they're like hey what do you think about
Mike Tyson [__] Mike Tyson I'll [__] him
up I'm [__] him up right now
they're like Beetlejuice yeah we heard
that Beetlejuice was talking [__] to you
like oh [__] I'll [__] that guy up I'll
[__] him up [__] him
he's my number one by far get us some
Beetlejuice clips get on the YouTube all
right this is gonna be it's gonna be a
rabbit hole for us
and Jamis Jameis Winston is my number
one NFL player what happened let's talk
about what happened with Jameis Winston
while Riley miles looking this up what
happened to Jameis Winston last year in
the NFL he didn't play I don't know why
there must be some bigger reason and
this isn't talked about why he didn't
play over Andy why he played two weeks
and then didn't I mean they never put
him back in
what do you think it's something must
have occurred because there's there's no
Andy Dalton is mid right
yes he's ask any Cincinnati fan he was
there for nine years right it was mid
the whole way right how do you get a
there's no way you don't try Jameis
Winston at some point
but I mean do you feel like that I mean
just in there do you feel like they had
seen Jamis and they're like this we kind
of know we're gonna get
but I mean I think a lot of saints fans
are like over the top about Sheamus oh I
think tons of Saint pans were like why
would you not put take at least he's at
least gonna be higher or low it's like
at least it'll be exciting
right it was the most boring mundane
safe bet season ever something else must
have happened there was no reason at
some point I don't know it could be like
a contract thing it could have been like
he's gonna be up for a renewal maybe
they wanted to keep him I don't know
maybe they talked to him maybe he's like
look I'm out of here after this year
you're you guys are moving on yeah let's
just keep me I don't I don't know man
he's like I don't want to play
could have been it don't play me right
I don't want to do it yeah no I thought
you should know
I don't want to play all right
okay
but being back a quarterback best job in
the world oh so good man pick up a few
Mills just sit there everyone loves you
people love shoulders hurt a little bit
probably from what shoulder pads on the
sideline Oh I thought you meant from
keeping your hopes from holding your
hopes I think you just get rid of those
things just get that cash [__] there
never get hurt don't take any hits don't
have to really practice that hard
yeah
what do we got Beetlejuice right here
oh Beetlejuice the movie Riley
maybe yeah maybe uh Beetlejuice Howard
Stern maybe will be a good uh
but how do you not know what we're
looking for right here
do I say could do 150 push-ups right now
well I'm I'm not he's never Master but
he's never ejaculated in his life yeah
probably could do more than that though
Riley man what do we got going on what's
in the news over there Riley
San Francisco reparations five million
dollars uh what is this article good
onto the document Riley let's zoom in a
little
payments of five million dollars to
every eligible black adult the
elimination of personal debt and tax
burdens guaranteed annual incomes of at
least 97 000 for 250 years and homes in
San Francisco for just a dollar a family
these are some of the recommendations
maybe our city appointed reparations
committee
tasked with the thorny question what
would it take to atone for centuries U.S
slavery dude I would then I would do but
I'd do blackface in a heartbeat and move
to San Francisco
wait is this a this is someone that said
uh
this is someone who said what would it
take to basically make up for slavery or
this is something that said we should do
this they want to do this in San
Francisco they want to give five million
dollars to everybody there weren't even
any slaves in San Francisco
they don't even do it
[Music]
dude that's a [__] great San
Francisco literally means no slaves
yeah it means without Francisco
that's they're acting up wow that's true
I think it's a good idea yeah I see
where they're coming from oh yeah I get
the understanding but it's like yeah I
think dude you're gonna have a lot of
people dying their skin and moving over
there okay
bro I would definitely dog you're gonna
have I'm putting tannins in I'm doing
everything bro
I'm taking collagen blockers whatever I
gotta do bro I'm drinking Hank I'm
[__] getting in dog dude I would do
slavery I wouldn't be a slave dude for a
year or something oh bro sign me up dog
I would [__] you yeah I'd move to
Florida and work for somebody dude yeah
I would do something bro
this it was the ninety seven thousand
dollars five million dollar how many
dollars is to do forever for 250 years
they're not even gonna be alive oh it
sounds like Beetlejuice answered the
question three million dollars ninety
seven thousand one dollar per family
everyone gets it for two you get it for
250 years
damn bro it's gonna be interesting do
you think though that after the 250
years families would be like okay
they're just gonna how easily after that
are they just gonna be like all right
cool we're cool with not getting that
money no people would want to continue
to get that money I think they would do
and then be like I don't know you know
that we could probably I don't know but
I'm over it yet
right hey we need another 10 years yeah
let me let me really digest what's been
happening in 250 years dude there's not
gonna be a planet
see maybe they know that and now they're
trying to that's probably what's
happening dude 97 000 250 years from now
is gonna be like a Coke
well if you got to keep it but it was
like the lottery you didn't get it until
you serve your 250. oh
yeah
yeah you just it keeps building up in an
account somewhere I don't know if this I
mean look I don't know
I don't know
but yeah I think you can't how are you
how do you know
if somebody was part of slavery or not
if their family was
the San Francisco
yeah they weren't
that's true
yeah that's true yeah I think you got
them yeah you gotta come east a little
bit maybe at least two songs
like what
I respect ultimate respect what else we
got Riley in the news
Tarpon Springs man this is around by you
isn't it probably arrested replacing
camera inside men's restroom at we spy
coffee and more what they we spy coffee
and more yeah and Tarpon Springs
arrested Tarpon Springs arrested 31 year
old spy plus listen to his name spy
Ryden yeah so if he's [__] dude
whether they want him to do his name's
spy riding at the Spy Store what exactly
do you think this guy's gonna do
yeah dude it's a spy store
we spy coffee what do they do at the
place Riley come on get us into the uh
stuff uh place his phone in the bathroom
under the sink to record man he found
attractive oh he was gay and
the defendant advisor imagine you walk
into the bathroom and then he cut this
dude walks in he's like sorry sorry
picks up his phone he's like nah dude
you ain't cutting it not to me yeah yeah
dude I ain't filming this beat dude you
wash your hands walking he puts it back
and walks out behind you
uh what else he got this doesn't do it
for me Riley wait can we do one thing
Riley can you just type in we spy coffee
and more let's just get a look at the
place yeah that's a good call
and I just wanted yeah we'll just see
what the more is Maybe
yeah what is it Go click on the business
over there on the right Raleigh
Florida Sponge coffee we've had a few
more employee arrested over spying
Hey look
okay
you can't get upset if you go to a place
called we spy coffee and more
as somebody spies on you in that [__]
so that was a setup they got his ass
that's a frame job dude hey
[Laughter]
thought you should know I thought you
should know dude
all right let's get him what else we got
Riley
what you got what's going on with you
Riley we haven't checking with you in a
while rally now if you guys have ever
met each other this is my first time
meeting them so the first thing that we
said to each other was um
hey and then he said
well you were gone he said that he took
a lot of pre-workout so he's on pre-work
right pre-workout right now and he could
probably push out 150. I said there's no
way that's true but I didn't know a
thing about not ejaculating number which
I don't believe
um and I'm not saying he's a liar but I
just don't believe it sounds like you're
saying that he's a liar dude one time I
was in one of the things we did early in
my career I was had so many ideas yeah
well like what happened one of my uh
interns at the time he was intern at
barcel wasn't necessarily mine but he
was a young fellow at bar stool
we uh we saw how long he could go
without coming and so basically the
rules were no sex no masturbation no no
do anything that mentally will excite
you to that point
you basically just have to live your
life as a Earnest and faithful man
and we'll see how long you go before you
just come
and he went 21 days wow in his sleep
so your body comes all the time
is that true Riley
yeah Riley give us an update you and I
haven't checked in in a while either
Riley give us an update and I hate to
just get right into your sexual nature
but when the last we checked you'd never
ejaculated is that honestly what what
you're saying uh that is true and where
are you at now with it still haven't but
Riley and if Theo's not gonna do it I
definitely don't want to do it because
we just met I'm not comp making I'm not
coming him or whatever
insane and I'm trying to come him either
okay I don't want to come him either but
do you have you ever woke up like you
woke up and then you had done it in your
dreams or something like that
uh no no not that I could think of
what do you mean that you could think of
have you ever woken up and it seemed
like somebody had
you know shot a scene of Ghostbusters in
your pants
uh no not really see that's and I find
it tough sometimes to believe him but
that's what you did out there at the
hunting trip wake up look down here
I thought you said no
oh damn somebody shot a gobbler
's in there dude we got to get a uh we
got to get a like a turkey sound and
just drop it in like throughout the
episode
who's in dead moments where there's no
sound Riley what's the most so how's the
Dayton life been for you what's been
going on buddy
uh I've been getting out there more and
more but uh still still single
and he's not gonna burst or nothing
until he's uh wedded in wedlock is part
of his
um religious affiliation is that right
bud that's correct man so do you like I
mean do you that's a and that's part of
like if you're doing Christianity of
probably Muslim like a main the main
religions I feel like that's part of it
so do you feel like do you does it make
you nervous Riley to be like
to just think about
just that you might do it and get
married and then get nervous that like
it will go just not go how you want it
to or like how do you want it how do you
want it to go the first time yeah I mean
I feel like it's gonna you know you know
I'm gonna be nervous and you know
nothing's gonna yeah and what sorry go
on I mean it might not be as you know
what I hope but you know we'll see it
may how much you think is in there
in him that is a long time how old are
you 24. yeah that's how long how much do
you think is in there can you feel it oh
at least one of those like medium ice
cream cups
uh no I don't feel it
yeah okay never mind I'm not gonna say
we don't know each other we're kicking
out he's very open about it and we've
discussed it over the years is that he's
waiting for God do you ever just pray
that God touches you in your sleep or
anything like that I don't
do you feel like you do you feel like
you are carrying the extra like do you
feel like your body has stopped your
body is like tuned into what you're
doing and it's like all right let's just
shut down the production of this stuff
for now until we got a wife or do you
feel like it's still making it and if so
where do you think your body's holding
it like if you ran out of room and your
testicles or wherever it is where do you
think your your reservoirs are
um no I just you know I just don't think
about it I don't really have any urges
it never came across in my mind
but you in your mind what are you
talking about like surely you think
about women and stuff yeah oh yeah all
the time okay so but then how do you
prevent it from getting to that sexual
space where you're thinking about
pleasuring yourself or rubbing your body
on the carpet until you ejaculate
uh it just never gets to that point
do you think it's because like you have
good self-control or do you think that
you were just blessed with like a
unproverted disposition so you're just
you just got kind of lucked out
basically yeah I think it's a mixture of
both
that's the part I have trouble believing
sometimes and I don't mean I'm not
calling you out about it but do you feel
like dormant
do you feel like your wiener is dormant
yeah pretty much
that's [__] crazy
I mean but how are you going to get I
mean how are you going to take that into
a married marriage
ah I I don't know it'll probably just
you know happen when it happens do you
worry that when it does happen it'll be
too much like you just held so much of
it so over the years that it would just
be when it does come out it would be so
much yeah like you're gonna have to call
the manager or whatever
oh probably but I mean that might be a
good thing oh geez dude how many so how
many kids do you think you're carrying
in your body right now oh geez maybe six
six
damn dog you're like a dang semen mule
well that's crazy bud what else do you
have any interesting dates recently
Raleigh ah kinda I I have a friend
that's been uh getting me out there more
meeting other girls at you know random
places
and if you had to describe these girls
like what type of women like what
ethnicity or something give me one word
to describe them uh mostly white uh very
cute blonde brunette doesn't matter
um
yeah
do you worry about meeting someone and
like you meet the woman that you really
the kind of woman of your dreams and
then
you think it's the one but then at kind
of the last minute she pulls out like
hey I want to see if I want to see if
this this volcano goes off you know I
just want to test it for if it works
because maybe she doesn't wanna
give me you know go into a lifelong
commitment just to make sure that the
yeah say you meet some broad and she
wants to come you up a little before you
guys get hitched what what do you do
what will you say
man I would I would probably uh can you
do that or you can't
I don't know I never really thought
about that
well what do you mean it's like dude
what are your rules like can you do it
or not
you know like that's what I'm saying
buddy I just you know you know what I'm
asking him yeah I think the rule
probably is just no can't do it damn
man well
it's amazing I can't I don't know
anything that hasn't ejaculated in 24
years
except for him
well he has
he has never he has
you think he's lying yeah well because
it'd be harder to say that if he was in
this room but since he's in the Next
Room I can tell you he's lying that's
true I don't want to say it to his face
but he's lying and and Riley I don't
mean that like that you've done it to
yourself or anything like that but I do
think it is it's science yeah that your
body will do it and that's what that was
our experience uh our experiment at
Barstow was will his name's Robbie we
said when will Robbie's Body do it
itself yeah when will it release itself
if Robbie's not gonna do it when we'll
release itself and it's 21 days oh wow
so I think it's around I think it's I
think you can carry carry it for about a
month before it does it in your sleep
yeah
that's what Kevin Gates says he does it
all the time in his sleep really because
he's he's a semen retender oh yeah
Daddy's agent or whatever yeah so he
said all the time he's just waking up
just sticky sticky pants
a lot of guys are doing that uh deficit
deficus edging or whatever you don't
poop poop yeah yeah and you just try to
go as long as you can or whatever
you know that's how Elvis Presley died
he was a routine retained so much uh
defecate in his body did you hear the
thing about the Plastics in our waters
are making our taints smaller dude I was
thinking about that the other day I was
like do you think that
because there's the area between our
butts and our balls are getting smaller
and smaller because I guess there's
plastic in our water
even hearing yourself say that sounds
really crazy if I was just thinking dude
what if we could figure out a way to
well we could figure out a way to
reverse it and exp expand the tank
and get it up here yeah I love that bro
you can tell how someone's Health just
by how tall their balls were
I thought about getting my balls
completely taken off right yeah so it's
just all weiner no balls imagine that
dude
I bet chicks with dig Dad if you're like
hey it's all dick no nuts honey
foreign
looking at that yeah but still I think
it seemed with so much more aerodynamic
you know it would look so good oh it'd
be like a [__] it'd be like a like a
Lamborghini down there
you know sometimes I feel like it's like
a nice like little bed kind of like kind
of like a hammock almost yeah resting
yeah it would just have no no friends no
one to hang out with and your penis
would end up not to be gross end up
getting in touching your oh that's a
good point now you're talking yeah
that's true you'd have a lot more
propensity to maybe do self-gaying dude
you got a sauna you got your blood
flowing all of a sudden you never know
what's happening dude some guys in class
he's just shoving his wiener into his
butt for no reason just because he's
bored
hey Randy what are you doing back there
like oh my bad man
it's killing time
hey don't use a no
what else we got Riley any more news or
what
oh we've got
what about oh let's I want to get Glenny
balls to come in here sometime yeah you
know yes and you said he's a very
interesting man he's an Italian man yeah
he is actually and he has the new he has
an only Stan show right yes and it is
more about talking with only fans women
yeah do you think he is going to end up
in some type of
um pornography or do you think it gets
to that sort of a slope or has best case
scenario
is that he ends up pouring doing porn
I just he I mean
I just don't know what he wants out of
it
little sex probably I'm sure he's
meeting a lot of women and they all want
to bang him and he says no oh he's
saying no he won't do it because it
probably is a conflict of work I guess
it's a business thing right Gotta Stay
professional it makes sense but now
because he says no all the girls
they had it's like a challenge it's like
who can be the only fans model to take
down Glennie balls it's like an award
it's like a gobbler yeah
dude he's a horny guy is he yeah I love
him god dude okay this is a weird
thought yeah do you feel like horny guys
are more fun to be around even though
you're not trying to [__] them that's a
good question dude sometimes I feel like
being around horny guys is fun
right now
dude it's like I'm bored but this guy is
he's got natural energy he's like yeah I
don't know yeah this guy's spruced up
well I'm not saying that's how I feel
I'm just saying to you
what do you say to people who say what
do you say people say it's fun to be
around horny guys
I don't know I don't think I will say
this once guys get married they become
there's less kind of like that energy is
you know they're more excited I think
about getting out and getting drunk and
stuff but they don't have that same like
they can't do sex anymore it's like a
Vitality like people have that Natural
Energy it's kind of like yeah oh it's
definitely fun a lot of times though
it's like like my buddy and I used to go
eat sometimes and if there weren't any
cute girls at the restaurant he'd be
like let's leave and go to another
restaurant
sometimes it's a little too much you
know yeah and then also you get like
kind of how Michael Waddell has that
like switch where you just we want we
had a fun time with turkey hunting both
days but the second day after we've been
out there four hours we're like all
right let's go home and eat and he said
all right I'm gonna stay here and kill a
turkey hey you guys hey I'm a kill
turkey sometimes you get that with guys
too like okay but like I was serious
about this the whole time it might be
fun for you watching me get warmed up
but I'm serious
yeah it's like almost like like Antonio
Cromartie with having kids you know when
other people are like hey man good game
today we're gonna fly back on the team
Jen he's like I'm gonna stay in town and
have a kid
um
what else is going on Caleb I don't know
when we'll see each other again dude
we've seen each other enough yeah you're
right man yeah yeah you're right about
that dude no you're coming to Florida oh
yeah that's true that's right I'll see
that on there like two weeks two weeks
what'd you think about Florida I kind of
wanna I'm starting to think about a
recruiting strategy to get you out of
Nashville down to Florida just because I
like to make people doing things that I
do in life like whether it's I was
recruiting people in Nashville I had my
lease was about to be up in a month I
was trying to get people to move here
people get into like where are you like
I moved yeah
um oh I really liked it man we were down
near like Jupiter Boynton Beach kind of
you know it's uh oh it's nice you go
outside there's just there's a breeze
there's the beach is right there you go
out and you feel the Lord just looking
at you and I don't think that happens
you know uh Nashville is nice it just
but it doesn't have that beach it
doesn't have that it doesn't have that
energy in the air where it just feels
like everybody's there for a good time
yeah that's one thing that happens in uh
that's more at the beach and it feels a
little bit healthier probably down there
I think it's a lot healthier yeah I mean
people a lot of stuff here is like you
know people are drinking it's a big
drinking culture golf
um
so I had to give a lot of those things
there was a moment in my recruiting I
was still early I haven't thought about
my strategy but I was trying to tell you
that people in Nashville are drinking
too much and you need to move to Florida
I'm wearing the math in my head I was
like well that might not be my best
pitch
yeah dude people are mostly
Florida hammered
it's got It's got Sun Tans would you say
your response was like uh yeah at least
these guys gonna get cancer and die at
least these guys are good not gonna live
for I don't remember what you said yeah
there's less cancer in Nashville
um
yeah I don't know what but it's
definitely very peaceful it's nice
what else I'm trying to think of being
so General about it oh it's so I can't
wait to go back at least and have
another experience of just a relaxing
experience
you know another I would I think I'm
gonna go for a few days before
the uh
that UFC in Miami this is what this is
my best pitch so far that I've thought
of that makes sense in Nashville because
I lived here for six months so I know
what it's like
when you get to that point of the day
maybe it's the afternoon you kind of
already did your work or maybe you've
got some more to do but you're kind of
tired you need to take a break okay
what are you doing at three o'clock in
the afternoon in Nashville
what are you gonna do you want to take a
break what are you doing
I don't know maybe go for a like go out
to
the um Lake over there and go run or
something you're not doing anything
you're not doing that dude you're not
you're not doing that
dude you asked me today you're like hey
do you want to go on a run and then uh
before the podcast I was like sure and
then you're like yeah I don't really
want to do that so let's just [__]
not do that
I want to do it either to be honest with
you I was like I guess that sounds fun
you're like no I don't yeah I fell apart
fast boy that [__] fell apart fast dude
bro what do you think about this do you
think a lot of gay men go in the
military just to meet other men
and just pretend they want to fight dude
my massage therapist in Florida it just
met her she works with all my friends
who were like who were like athletes and
they like need massage therapists and I
just started going just because I'm kind
of bored yeah and she was in the
military and then her job next job out
was fake prostitute
so she she just was
I don't know how far do you think you
have to go with a guy if you're fake
prostitute and before you catch up like
before you throw up the badge
and do you think they believe you if
you're butt naked in there do you think
and they don't have the badge to show
you think they even believe you oh yeah
what if you forget your badge at home
you're like [__] you're just [__]
some dude you're like uh I'm you're
under arrest
well dude we were fake prostitutes out
of the turkey this is exactly what we
were there was literally turkey hunt is
literally like being it's like a strip
club or something like that and then the
girl comes up to you and she's like hey
you want to get this private room you're
like I don't know how much it's gonna
cost like uh oh it's cheap they talk you
down you're like I don't really want to
do it honestly like I'm not trying to do
that it's not why I'm here and they talk
you into it you get in there and they
blow your brains out
yeah the second you walk in dude
yeah the second you walk in there's like
seven other dudes standing there with
erections and then they blow your
[__] brains out
oh God
thought you should know that's just
everybody starts singing thoughts you
should know and then they blow your
brains out that's exactly what the key
on is dude you hide behind like some
Ferns and [__] right it's like behind
seven ferns without Zach Galifianakis
right so you hide behind a bunch of
ferns you make a bunch of sounds like
hey don't you want somebody that's cool
hey
Cooter body hey you just make sounds you
like make sounds of like tits just
beating against each other just
random sounds then when somebody finally
comes around the bush to see him a bunch
of dudes stand up and be like thought
you should know and they [__] just
blow your [__] brains out
[Music]
but it was fun man
come on I think we've probably covered a
lot huh I don't know I know well
anything else you need to talk about
what's on your mind
um
do I I'm sorry about what we said
earlier I'm feeling bad about it I'm not
someone needs to figure out we've long
wondered how much what is the reality of
it and people say it a lot is Riley
really
how real could this be that this man
refuses to ejaculate in a very
ejaculatory world
yeah no it's it's 100 real
you feel like your joints work better
and stuff like that like
uh I just wondering where is it going
because it's going somewhere because
like you're a human body it's all
backing up in you like your whole body
is full of saving how how much food can
you eat before you're full
uh a lot but do you fall and like cut
your leg and it feels so good like
what's coming out of you that's what I
wonder when you bleed like is it white
uh no it's red damn sheesh I feel like
he's not giving us much information do
you I mean it's a sensitive thing to
talk about I understand why he would not
want to give us information particularly
me since I don't know him but it is
interesting because it sounds like it's
he's lying
yeah and I'm sorry Riley am I making you
uncomfortable no no not at all okay
would you tell Caleb the truth yeah yeah
that that was 100 the truth will you
tell me the truth when after Theo leaves
I will okay will it be the same truth
you've already told him yep
[Music]
uh
uh what else we have Caleb dude no it's
crazy it's like I don't know how long
we've been going if you started Morgan
wallen's album before we started and you
listen to our whole podcast it would
still be going that's true that's a long
time [__] five hours long
and you'd still be listening to the
number ones that's the crazy part we're
like Morgan wallen's stands are we
stands for Morgan Wallen I love them
yeah
I love his music he's a he's I've met
him enough times I think he's a cool
good guy
he's really funny I don't know if people
get to see that side of him very much
and [__] bangers dude he just you know
what I've been seeing a lot illusionally
is like his clips of his like earlier
life are starting to circulate oh really
when he he kind of looked like Keith
Urban a little bit you've seen that
um yeah different type of haircut
um yeah yeah there's a voice there's
videos of him I know when he was like uh
auditioning and stuff for different
shows how he feels about that now
because look I mean at the time he's
probably really excited to be on the
voice it's like a big opportunity now I
wonder if he looks back at it like I
shouldn't have done that or if he thinks
it like helped them
yeah it's a good question I think one
thing we don't realize is all little
things have a play in where we are
whether we want to admit it or not right
because they they affect how you also
then want to do things right it may have
said him you know I don't want it you
know I don't want to do my own thing
more I don't you know I like some of
this but I don't like a lot of it if I
would have never done that experiment on
Robbie Fox with the coming I would I
would not think he's lying right but
since I did that experiment in my life
I know for fact that he's coming at
night time
or even worse or more more liarish
during the day
right now I don't even know what he's
doing right now dude well he's all
Riley's kind of a smaller and stature
guy how tall are you Riley
I am 5'4 and so how much scene I mean
he's like has fulla
yeah you got a lot in you man oh God
it'd be beautiful I just
I think you men a lot of older gay men
would pay to watch him come the first
time as sad as that is it's kind of like
Glennie balls now with so many girls
like since he's not and he's out and
he's you know I don't want to spill his
information but he's he's active in the
community but not with these
these type this group of women right
these only fans women to my knowledge
you could be lying as well about that
that's what he's saying yeah so it's
like a it's like a pride thing for these
girls I think like they're gonna the top
they're gonna see who can do it to
Glenny balls I think the same could
probably be said about a lot of your
listeners male listeners with him
or a female I mean I don't think it's
but I think there's a lot of men out
there that even straight men that would
probably pay to watch him do it the
first time I would I would pay I would
pay to know how much it was just to know
someone just gave me text me the number
of inches or they filled up in like the
water bottle
do you feel like you know you pee
sometimes in the car and then you you're
like I'm a penis water bottle and then
it you feel it all the way like oh I got
to cut this stream off or something it's
going to come out the top yeah like I
wonder if it would be the same thing
he's just gotta Kink the hose and get
another water bottle almost like when
they're taking blood and then to do that
thing and then grab the next one yeah
damn how much you think you got in your
Riley
uh probably a lot damn bro gross dude
now we could do this we could have a
thing even for charity where we get
people to bit like guess a number
like how much little hectounces or heck
you know little mint you know kilo
ounces or whatever it is and whoever
gets the closest but you can't do it for
your own uh religious purposes you can't
that's why you're not masturbating is
that right Riley correct okay this is a
this is a question is all this time
itself sorry about this man yeah we're
probably yeah this is insane the
question is oldest time itself it's the
question usually is
would you kill one person to save a
million people
you have to murder one person but you
know that it saves a million people
you'll never see but if you don't murder
that person that's in the room with you
those a million people although you
might not see them
they're going to pass away
would you
fill up a water bottle to save those
million people
I would probably not you would let them
die
I mean I don't want to I don't want to
kill a man it'll be a million of them
and children and women
well that's not my problem I'm not
killing them that's a good point yeah
he's just not masturbating that's his
rules facts damn he stands by his rules
my bad that's good oh Kayla Presley what
else we got man dude I don't know but I
do have to peel a little bit we go on a
frog like probably an hour and 45
minutes Bradley
yeah a little yeah pretty much okay I
think we probably finish it up here I
don't know if there's anything else we
need to talk about
I'm trying to think too if there's
anything we did that we could uh would
you ever have like Will Smith on your
show you think Will Smith
you think I should I don't know I I
think about it kind of like there's some
guys who not that don't like Will Smith
but like
would it fit it's not gonna be a good
episode right
right
you can't really go for like
it doesn't really fit in like what is
like publicity you gotta have real you
have people who have real reactions and
have like a real some people just been
famous for way too long and they and
they're too good at their two media I
don't know if I would have the rock on
it's two Media train times it's too
Media train it's like what are you gonna
get out of the rock yeah
I'll have you on again would you ever
come on again
yeah I think I would like to go on again
you know I was supposed to come and help
Rose Morgan when he came on your episode
yeah I know damn
that would have been good he doesn't
even know that I know he doesn't let's
don't tell him yeah
um
dude honestly I just have to piece of
bed I don't think I can think of
anything else that's fine like feeling
like
I can feel how he feels yeah all the
time
um you want to get something to eat
what time is it I don't know 4 30. let's
go do something to eat all right should
we do like a last thing or like a
send-off or like a apology to Riley
yeah I think maybe we can just say Riley
we appreciate and respect whatever
Journey that you're on
and
are you going to be okay no matter what
yeah I think so
okay and are you okay if other people
are sexually active you have judgment
against those people
uh no no they just they can live their
lives as they please Amen brother
I mean it's crazy to be out there and be
like and to be doing it you know I'm
saying I'm very envious probably do you
think I mean obviously Theo or you know
some people think there's people out
there that think that's fun to hang
around horny guys
do you think that
ah yeah
yeah do you find it more exciting to be
around horny guys would you rather hang
out with a horny guy or a guy who's kind
of
maybe just thinking about something else
probably a horny guy yeah
why it's more fun
why
I just feel like there they would be
more fun than just the guy that's well
like me no no Riley I mean that that's
that's not yeah buddy you're doing good
man
that's a myth also I think that I'm I'm
gonna choose to believe what you're
saying
not that it probably means anything to
you all right but I think that I
I personally feel like we've put you
kind of through the lit in this test of
every question you could think of
and all of your answers there all your
answers hold up kind of like if you yeah
none of your answers contradict one
another
which I think is a good good sign
yeah no I I appreciate it Caleb for sure
yeah and I think in the gay community
it's called a Snick uh cinnamon cookie
or something if somebody's never
ejaculated
do you fear that you could be involved
in the gay community Riley definitely
not okay
and not fear but is it you know have you
thought are you scared for your life
yeah no you telling the truth I mean
yeah I I do want to look it up though
yeah we'll investigate it man but look
in the meantime uh love you guys Caleb
pressy thank you this is probably the
last time you'll ever be in Nashville
unless we come back to fight this
busting with the boys dudes all right
let's that's you dude that's your
journey those are my friends are they
what
I love those guys they had beef huh you
told me they had beef y'all got beef man
yeah you're right no I would definitely
stick up for I would just be there you
know I would be like the uh the mom at
that Kelsey Super Bowl oh
I'll cry and then celebrate but then who
and my tag team pardon me then
Riley probably no I need somebody that's
got that gun I need somebody that's well
actually
no um
no it's a good question
all right boys and girls let's give you
something to eat huh yep all right Caleb
Pressley good to see you man good to see
you brother yeah I probably won't see
you for I'll see in a couple weeks
[Music]
the funniest thing was you like
um we were driving in my house you're
like I was like I live right here like
oh man it's a nice spot
two seconds later so where do you live
out here
[Music]
come on right over there oh oh yeah nice
hey bro
that's what's going on baby that's where
we're at man yeah thanks for having me
dude I think that this uh
foreign
Michael Waddell thank you for the hunt
uh Caleb Presley thank you for being
here today uh we'll see you guys next
time
[Music]
Cornerstone
I'll share this piece of my life
[Music]